which battles in which armies go to war
with machines of death and destruction
in mid-December before targeting Greta
tunberg on Twitter Andrew Tate posted a
trademark hyperbolic video to his
millions of followers promoting his
latest get rich quick scheme every
single thing that exists out there is
some Matrix is done so with a purpose
The Matrix a reference to the movie
about a subjugated brainwashed
population
on Thursday night during his arrest he
mentioned it again the Matrix has
attacked me still on brand even as he
and his brother were detained in
connection with a human trafficking and
rape investigation Romanian prosecutors
claim an organized crime group was
sexually exploiting six people
police video of the raid on Tate's home
showing weapons cash and fast cars
the former kickboxer has long courted
controversy he was kicked off a British
reality TV show in 2016 after a video
emerged of him appearing to beat a woman
with a belt in Romania and I explain my
five reasons one of them is the metoo
era since then his misogynistic comments
have had him thrown off major social
media platforms he has said women are a
man's property and that rape victims
should bear responsibility for their
attacks I get called Morpheus all the
time in my DMs because I'm trying to
wake people up but he has still made a
fortune from that content Tate's fans
pay him to learn how to make ad Revenue
by reposting his most controversial
Clips which has led to his sharp rise in
prominence in the past year an
investigation from The Observer
newspaper said his subscribers were told
you want arguments you want war it's
worked out really well for the companies
too because they've made tons of money
by placing ads next to his must-see
content because it's must see not just
for those who like it but also for those
who dislike it despite hates misogyny
the sometimes Free Speech Champion Elon
Musk reinstated Tate on Twitter in
November while under arrest someone has
continued to post from Tate's Twitter
account Redmond Shannon Global News
London